what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and I don't know what it is but I
have always loved a good revenge story I
guess there's something to be said about
the bad guy getting what's coming to
them they get their just desserts
and it's also sweet when I think about
revenge
I think of inigo montoya from The
Princess Bride getting revenge on the
six-fingered count as an 11 year old kid
he witnesses the calculus father who had
just spent a year making a beautiful
sword for the noble he challenges the
count to a duel but quickly gets
disarmed he has to face his own
powerlessness he can't get revenge right
away so he devotes himself to becoming
stronger he dedicates his life to
training and becoming a great swordsman
so that he can get his revenge and
eventually at the age of 35 he gets his
chance as he practiced many times he
tells his father's killer hello my name
is Inigo Montoya you killed my father
prepare to die the years of training and
preparing for this one moment have paid
off even though he's injured he gets the
upper hand against the count and then
Inigo tells the count to offer him money
power and anything else he asks for the
count is begging to be spared he agrees
to give him everything he wants and more
then after ask him to make the offers in
Eagle stabs him and tells him that he
wants his father back and so ends my
favorite part in the entire movie even
though an Eagle is just a side character
the revenge he planned for his entire
life finally came to fruition his father
can rest easy and the count has been
punished for his crimes anime like other
works of fiction is full of similar
moments of revenge that are when done
right deeply moving and satisfying in
this video we're going to be looking at
some of my favorite Avenger moments in
anime but as with my best geniuses in
anime videos I'll make more installments
if you want to see more so if we can get
2000 likes I'll make a part 2 make sure
to leave some of your favorite bench
moments in the comments and thank you to
everyone who responded on the anime
uproar Instagram post with suggestions
you brought up some great examples that
I completely overlooked so I now have
plenty of material for future
installments thanks to you
also if you haven't already make sure to
subscribe and bring that notification
bell so you get notified when new videos
like this one come out keep in mind
these videos do include some anime
spoilers and
later on in this video I'll include some
manga spoilers but I'll warn you again
before I do so sit back relax and enjoy
these sweet moments of revenge gong
couch sold the cattle Montecristo
actually sparked the idea for this whole
video series the kind of Montecristo
book that inspired the anime was the
first non kid book that I read all the
way through it was over 1000 pages long
and I loved it to this day it is still
one of my favorite books ever and I have
a master's degree in literature so
that's saying a lot even though I read
it so long ago the story stays with me
because it's such a great and satisfying
revenge story and even though the anime
adds sci-fi elements and vampires the
revenge plot that made the original so
good is retained the story goes as
follows edmond dantes was a space sailor
and he had a lover named Mercedes but as
is the case with subaru from re0 she
wasn't actually a car things were
looking good for our young edmond he had
humble beginnings but he was about to
marry the woman he loved and he had just
received a nice promotion that would
help ensure his family's financial
stability then he was framed for murder
by don lars and fern on fern on his best
friend wanted to get with Mercedes while
danglers hated Edmonds honesty and and
meet his promotion enter a third rotten
apple called Vil for Bill for was
involved in a plausible conspiracy so he
helped imprison admin in the Chateau
d'If to protect himself the innocent
good-hearted Edmond spent years enduring
mental torture and living in the most
subhuman conditions you can imagine
without even being allowed to take his
own life
then a demonic vampire asked being
called donkatsu
entered Edmonds body and helped him
escape after he escapes of course he
wants revenge on those who ruined his
life when he was arrested he was a
pretty poor naive and powerless young
man and he comes back 25 years later as
an insanely rich wise and powerful count
who is ready to execute his revenge the
passage of time as with Inigo Montoya's
revenge can add weight to any revenge
story Edmonds revenge is more extreme in
every way compared to Inigo Montoya's
though he had more to lose when he got
arrested it wasn't just his father he
lost his lover his job his freedom in
his aunt
life and then he doesn't just come back
as a better fighter he comes back as a
wealthy genius count with vampire powers
he sold his soul to get his revenge for
Edmund he doesn't just want to kill
those who wronged him as he says that
there's just a release from suffering
rather he orchestrates elaborate plans
so that those who wronged him
experienced true and lasting suffering
it begins with the money obsessed Don
Lars who has become a baron and a
powerful banker since he helped frame
Edmund as I said death would be too good
for his enemies in the counts opinion he
needs to destroy them in every way
before they die in the case of Don Lars
he escapes his creditors and skips town
with five trillion francs fYI that's a
lot of money so his reputations shot at
this point but he paid for a solo space
flight and it seems like he at least got
away with the money he loves so much
except the cattle Monte Cristo is on the
plane it seems that it's one of his
planes the cow confronts Don Lars you
might think that he'd take his money but
no that's too simple for the ingenious
count Edmund actually gives him more
wealth he reveals that there are gold
bricks all over the plane the count
references the tale of King Midas King
Midas wished that everything he touched
turned to gold and he got his wish but
he ended up not being able to eat
without turning his food into gold and
he even turned his own daughter into
gold by hugging her his wish turned out
to be a curse the tale is a warning
against greed and against becoming a
slave to our desires the count uses this
tale as inspiration for his revenge he
leaves Don Lars to rich money obsessed
banker with more wealth than he ever
could have imagined having however Don
Lars can't use the gold for anything
since he's been condemned to travel
through space alone until he dies with
nothing to soothe him but his now
useless wealth in such circumstances you
come to see just how utterly valueless
wealth is when it can't be traded for
anything this scene reminds us that
wealth is just a tool and should never
become an end goal in and of itself
then there's the count's revenge against
Vil for Crown prosecutor Vil for is less
concerned with money and more concerned
with reputation as a
Brown prosecutor he wants to maintain
the image of a just righteous man at all
costs in the past he had an affair and a
baby came from it he cared so much about
the opinions of others that he would
rather bury his own baby son alive in a
box that have news of the affair spread
unbeknownst the Ville for though his son
named Bandito was actually rescued and
survived the count orchestrates it so
that during Ville forest trial where he
is being accused of poisoning an
attempted murder the truth about his
affair and his son comes out vendetta
shows up reveals the truth to everyone
including the fact that bill for buried
him alive even the box he used for the
burial makes its way to the courtroom
then after will for his reputation the
most important thing to him is utterly
destroyed his own son stabs him with a
poisonous blade that makes Belfour go
crazy
he begins acting like a raving lunatic
with no sense of propriety thus the man
who was so obsessed with his reputation
becomes the man with the worst
reputation of all the count gets bonus
points for making the courtroom the
setting of bill for his downfall because
that is exactly where he exercised his
power over his powerless victims lastly
there's four Non the best friend who
betrayed edmund and stole his wife to be
the revenge on 4 Non is not complete but
the count nevertheless gets four not to
say that the count of everything from
him a deeply ironic line coming from
this backstabbing best friend even if
things didn't go exactly as the cow
planned for nan did have to pay for his
past Fernand was obsessed with being
nobler than the nobility and becoming
the strongest man in the military as a
general he stages a coup d'etat and if
he succeeds he'll get exactly what he
wanted he'll get a lot of power
thus when his wife tries to get him to
run away with her he doesn't just refuse
he also shoots her when she tries to
leave alone then his son shows up and
sees what he's done so he shoots him -
at this point he may well think he's
killed the two most important people in
his life the woman he betrayed Edmund
for and his only son this is why he
tells Edmund that he took everything
from him however both his wife and his
son survived his son even shows up at
the final fight between Fernand and the
count the count wants to kill Fernand
son al bear since he is the most
important person - for
and that's the best way to make him
suffer however gone coots will leaves
Edmunds body and the count dies before
he can carry out the final revenge still
though for non besides he needs to atone
for his sins and kills himself before he
ever gets a chance to see his dreams for
power carried out so in the end for non
lost his position the woman he loved in
betrayed Edmond for and his life - I
personally preferred the ending of the
book where there's no body controlling
vampire and Edmond survives realizing
that there is more to live for
beyond revenge but the anime still
included some of the most epic revenge
moments ever
even if it did eventually end with the
count dying
you can definitely say that everyone got
their just desserts
including the count himself who was
willing to kill innocent people like Al
bear in order to perfect his revenge the
Cata Monty crystal is special because
the whole story focuses on revenge
rather than revenge being a side thing
in the middle of a story about something
else we are given a chance to empathize
with the counts reasons for wanting
revenge and then we get to watch as he
takes his time in orchestrates the most
fitting punishment for everyone that
wronged him for these reasons I think
that the Kalamata crystal will always be
the best revenge story for me but that
doesn't mean there aren't deeply
satisfying revenge moments in other
anime so without further ado let's move
on and take a look at some more of the
best revenge moments that anime has to
offer next I want to talk about one
piece this instance that I'm about to
talk about is nowhere near as calculated
as the previous one but it is one of my
favorite moments in the entire manga and
for among as long as one piece that's
saying a lot I still recall how amazing
I felt after reading this part it
happens during chapter 502 to be
specific if you want to relive the glory
for yourself so let's jump into it at
this point in the manga a slave auction
is going on in a celestial dragon is
acting like a terrible person nothing
new if you didn't know celestial dragons
also called world nobles are descendants
of 19 of the 20 kings who establish the
world government they're pretty much
untouchable they can kill people or
abuse their powers in any other way and
get away with it because of their
privileged position they look down on
other people and refer to
them as commoners they actually looked
down on them so much that they wear
astronaut like helmets over their heads
so that they don't breathe in the same
air as the common people because whole
kingdoms can face destruction if they
are upset everyone even kings and queens
of other nations are expected to bow and
conform to the whims of the celestial
dragons they are used to getting
whatever they want they are insanely
entitled and they're just spoiled beyond
belief they have no empathy for others
and act without worrying about how they
may be hurting or disrespecting them
needless to say I hate them so much
HNO ordered the mangaka has done an
amazing job of constructing an extremely
unlikable spoiled group of people and
what makes it the worst is that they
never get punished for their horrible
behavior so knowing that let's go back
to the slave auction there is this
celestial dragon called Saint charlo s'
he is a 22 year old overweight dude with
noble snot coming out of his Imperial
nose at all times anyways he starts
beating one of his slaves for being too
slow he tells his sermon to sell him at
the auction then he says he wants a
mermaid but is told that they are hard
to catch Sanji sees the nobles enter and
he says that if they cross the nobles
they'll send a navy admiral after them
and the reader knows by now how
dangerous and strong those guys can be
in fact in an interview oda said that
admiral a canoe is so strong that if he
became the protagonist he could end the
one-piece series within a year in other
words a kind of finding the one piece
treasure and becoming The Pirate King
would be pretty simple for him if he
wanted to do it for this reason although
no one really likes celestial dragons
everyone even infamous Pirates are on
their best behavior around them after a
captured pirate bites off his own tongue
rather than being bought as a slave
commie the mermaid is finally brought
out our team plans to buy her freedom
with 200 million berries but Carlos is
not about to let a potential mermaid
slave escape he starts out with a
whopping bid of 500 million berries more
than double what Nami had to spend Hachi
our former antagonists turned octopus
friend starts to consider using force in
order to rescue commie Captain Kidd a
powerful
generation pirates simply laughs and
says and I quote that's how the world
works what a farce let's go then
Luffy breaks into the building Luffy
quickly starts running takami in order
to save her
while Hachi tries to stop him Hachi is
giving Luffy all of these reasons they
can go rescue her like she's wearing an
explosive collar and the celestial
dragons are here unlike everyone else
though Luffy doesn't care and tells them
that Comi isn't something they can sell
during these events people notice that
Hotch is a fish man and they're
disgusted because fish racism is common
on this island in the middle of all this
while people are trying to stop Luffy
Charlo suit on she suddenly Luffy has a
serious expression on his face and as we
all know when Luffy has a serious
expression on his face something's about
to go down while Charles is celebrating
having caught a free octopus Luffy
starts walking towards him Hachi grabs
Luffy's arm and tries to stop him Hachi
says it's his own fault and he reminds
Luffy that he promised not to cross the
celestial dragons Hachi starts to cry
there's a very emotional moment going on
while char los wants his shot octopus to
stop chattering after getting shot
Charlo says that Hachi is annoying him
Luffy then continues walking towards the
celestial again people warn him they
tell him he'll never get away with it
they don't know what he could be
thinking they can't believe that he's
serious and that's when the goosebump
inducing incident happens Luffy ignores
everything that people are telling him
to do he ignores everything that's
expected of him and he gives charlo the
greatest single punch to the face in all
of anime not only as Charles now
helmetless and thus breathing in
commoner air he's also knocked out and
bleeding what I love about this moment
is that charlo snare expected to pay for
his awful behavior all celestial dragons
have this feeling that they are
untouchable they feel like they can do
anything and completely get away with it
as we saw most people including pirates
do feel like they have to step aside and
let the nobles get away with whatever
they want to do however not Luffy
Luffy's punch is a revenge punch it's a
symbolic punch to the face of all
celestial dragons Luffy just let the
world know that even celestial dragons
aren't
touchable even they will get their just
desserts if they continue to act in a
terrible manner while everyone tiptoes
around celestial dragons Luffy just
straight-up knocked one out this moment
also speaks volumes about Luffy as a
character he acts freely without needing
permission from anyone he is not bound
by the fears and rules of society he has
his own moral compass and principles and
no matter the punishment he will do the
right thing in my opinion this is one of
the greatest moments in anime and in
large part it is because oda built up
the power abusing overconfidence less
steel dragons so well over the course of
the story that a single impromptu punch
in the face has as much impact as a well
planned out and executed plan that is
meticulously carried out over the course
of many years lastly let's talk about
Demon Slayer one of my favorite anime
and manga series right now there are
actually multiple instances of great
revenge moments but I want to focus on a
specific one in this video it has not
been animated yet so if you want to
avoid all manga spoilers I suggest you
click off the video right now when I
read the part that I'm about to mention
it was so good that I knew I had to
incorporate into a video and this is the
perfect video for it
now fellow manga fans and anime fans who
realize that getting spoiled is not a
big deal let's start approaching the
insect girls finest hour but in order to
fully appreciate the significance of
this revenge moment we have to look at
the past first shinobu kocho had an
older biological sister named kana
and the younger adoptive sister named
canal sweetie
long story short Shinobu never had a
good time with demons first demon
slaughtered her parents in front of her
and her older sister they were saved by
the rock pillar
Yomi himejima then because of the pain
and suffering they experienced because
of demons they both decided to become
demon Slayers so that they could protect
each other and other people as well they
didn't want what happened to them to
happen to other humans it was only later
that can I purchased a slave girl named
sue UT and brought her to the butterfly
estate Kenai was the flower pillar and
she eventually ran into Upper moon to
DOMA she received mortal wounds but the
Sun was coming up so DOMA had to flee
before he could eat her
Shinobu has a conversation with her die
sister kanae tries to get her sister to
quit the demon slayer core and live out
a normal safe life but Shinobu will
never be able to do that she decides at
this point that the rest of her life
will be dedicated to getting revenge on
her sister's killer connor passes away
but not before telling Shinobu about the
demon that killed her
so after losing her parents and her old
life to demons she trained with her
sister so something like that would
never happen again
nevertheless a demon showed up and
killed the last remaining member of her
original family and the most important
person in she Nobles life knowing this
it is no surprise that Shinobu doesn't
like demons especially this demon who
killed her sister with all this stuff in
mind it is no surprise that the chapter
in which she Nobu finally finds the
demon that matches her sisters
description is called
revenge no other chapters called revenge
which shows up to the mangaka this is
arguably the most important revenge
moment in the series so far Shinobu
recognizes DOMA as the demon who killed
her sister because he has blood stains
at the top of his head a carefree smile
and he speaks in a calm and gentle way
as if she Nobu doesn't have enough
reason to hate DOMA he also tries to
kill a girl that's present Walsh and
Nobu tries to save her it appears like
she does save her for a moment but in
truth dolmas attack was too quick to
register right away and after a second
almost cuts up here on the girl's body
and she instantly dies from the wounds
this scene not only serves to give
Shinobu more reason to hate him it also
serves to show how strong and fast DOMA
is and how tough it is going to be to
defeat him revenge is even more
satisfying when the opponent and
opponents seem overpowered and
untouchable and DOMA is quickly built up
as that kind of opponent in fact DOMA
uses ice powers which as we learn from
Pokemon are super effective against
flower and insect types my point is it
seems like Shinobu is at a huge
disadvantage in every way the odds seem
impossible especially since DOMA seems
to be able to decompose her poison
however we love the underdog and so we
root for Shinobu even more that is why
we are even more devastated when it
seems like Chanel was about to lose but
her sister's spirit appears before her
she tells her to pull herself together
Shinobu makes excuse
says saying she's lost so much blood she
punctured her left lung and she can't
breathe
but her sister spirit says and I quote
that doesn't matter
stand up insect Hashem Nobuko Cho once
you decide to defeat a demon defeat it
once you decide to win then win win
whatever the cost you made that promise
with Cano and me didn't you
Shinobu you can do this so do your best
and quote then Shinobu gets a second
wind and stands up even though most
humans would be dead after taking so
much damage the hype at this point is
real there's hope that she'll maybe pull
it off somehow
after all con I said she could do it
Shinobu believes that she can get her
poisoned blade into the upper moon's
neck she can kill him and perhaps save
hundreds of people from going through
what she went through she puts her all
into one final attempt and she succeeds
in getting her sword into dolmas neck
then she Nobu admits to herself that she
is angry at demons because they killed
her parents her older sister and all of
her to become a ka pillar successors
except Connell but all that anger seems
to be for nothing because the poison
attack didn't seem to work surprisingly
dolma cries he hugs Shinobu and calls
her so admirable
he says she tried so hard even though
she's such a weak girl this is probably
the worst way to anger Shinobu even
further she's getting pity from the
demon she hates more than anyone in the
world he goes on to insult her further
he says she is not as talented as her
sister that she's stupid enough to keep
trying he decides that she is worth
eating he asks her if she has any last
words and she tells him to go to hell
Carnell comes into the room but she
doesn't end up saving Shinobu since DOMA
absorbs her into his body quickly to be
honest I couldn't believe she was gone
when I first read this part I had to go
back and reread the pages to make sure
it really happened after all that
lead-up dolma succeeded in killing the
entire cultural family all that's left
is the adopted Connell we have to wait
over 10 chapters to get back to Cana vs.
DOMA for over 10 chapters we have to
swallow the fact that DOMA just
swallowed Shinobu and her dreams of
revenge
with her or at least that's what the
mangaka wants us to think
however she only does this so that the
impact that the revenge will be all the
more powerful the emotional
roller-coaster keeps going when we get
back to the fight Kyle calls out DOMA
for not being able to feel anything she
psycho analyzes him and figures out that
he's pretending to be happy to cover up
the truth that he can't actually feel a
thing
if DOMA has any insecurities it is
around his lack of emotions and so he
stops smiling he looks serious
and he tells Cano that he's never come
across a bully like her who says such
cruel things she wiped a smile off his
face so the psychological victory is
there now she needs to beat him
physically to make the revenge complete
which is easier said than done she
fights him and it seems like she's about
to lose before he knows he shows up and
saves her now as if the stakes were big
before the mangaka adds another twist
DOMA is also the demon who killed in
those case mother you see an auskey his
mother was from an abusive household and
she entered into his cult in order to
escape from the abuse however she found
out that DOMA was eating his followers
and tried to escape with her baby no
escape but DOMA caught up and she had to
throw in those K into a river
DOMA killed in Oscars mother but eNOS
gay escaped and survived the jungle book
style so now we have two characters with
insanely good reasons to want to kill
this overpowered demon then they fight
some more but the two are just no match
for DOMA just as it seems like he's
going to leave his face begins to break
down you see this was all part of
shinobis revenge including the part
where she gets eaten she had told her
sister that she would get eaten well in
advance of the actual battle she was
always prepared to sacrifice herself to
get her revenge and often a revenge is
even better - bigger - sacrifice and
your own life is one of the biggest
sacrifices you can make Shinobu used the
fact that DOMA has an obsession with
eating woman when planning out her
strategy
she knew that he'd eat a female pillar
like her and so she became more
poisonous than her blade could ever be
by consuming high concentrations of
wisteria flower poison her whole body
was filled with the poison all the way
down to the tips of her fingernails it
took her over a year of continued
taking in wisteria poison to achieve
this state she neared patience to carry
this plan out and she risked her life by
consuming the poison since no one had
ever attempted it before and the side
effects were unknown but it was worth
the risk
since compared to her sword which can
deliver 50 milligrams of poison in one
blow her body could deliver 37 kilograms
which is 70 times the lethal amount and
in order to increase the probability of
revenge
Shinobu did something she never thought
she would do in a million years she
works with demons namely Tamayo on
poison research even though she hated
demons so much in order to make sure
that DOMA is as we can buy her as
possible she sacrificed her life and
pride by working with the demon she
hated so much in order to carry out this
revenge plan now it's up to Connell any
norske to take advantage of her complete
sacrifice Khan now uses flower breathing
final form Vermillion eye which raises
dynamic vision to the utmost and makes
surrounding movement look dull and slow
the pressure that the technique puts on
the eyes causes them to bleed and stains
them red even if it means sacrificing
her vision she is willing to use it to
get close to DOMA and she succeeds she
man just to get her sword to his neck
but one of dolmas moves starts freezing
her body so that her arm has less and
less power behind it then
eNOS Kay who has been captured by an ice
buddha esque statue throws his blades at
dolmas neck and they help push Canelo's
blade through dolmas head is cut off
he's finally been defeated and both of
the people he's wronged played a crucial
part in executing Shinobu revenge plan
if that is one of the best revenge
moments an anime that I don't know what
is it had everything it had great
reasons for revenge it had time and
planning it had immense sacrifice it had
an overpowered near invincible target
and it had a double revenge decapitation
there's arguably no more satisfying
moment in demon slayer than this
perfectly calculated moment of revenge
dolma loss had a very woman he insulted
because she was too weak to even cut off
anyone's head and as a cherry on top of
the cake as DOMA is passing to the
afterlife
Shinobu spirit appears she holds up his
head and says and I quote now I too can
than piece and quote despite the fact
that DOMA seems to fall in love with
Shinobu rather than repent this is still
one of the best revenge moments I've
seen in a while
and if you have any better revenge
moments be sure to leave them in the
comments for the next installment and
that is it for today's video I hope you
enjoyed these revenge moments I know I
definitely did remember
I'll make a part two if we can get 2,000
likes on this video so like and share
this with someone who enjoys a good
revenge story if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and ring that notification
bell so you get notified when new videos
drop if that ain't enough anime
greatness follow us on Instagram and
Twitter for daily posts conversations
and updates a big thank you goes out to
our patrons over on patreon who help
make videos like this one possible I
especially want to thank our pro hero to
your patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson King
zelgius angel Cruz Steelers and Pablo
Pablo and are the one tier patrons the
ones who stand atop all clans baby ray
a17 ffvp Steven grata a Lola autumn
Matty Mac 239 makoto-kun keel on and
elrico dames and the patrons who
transcend greatness itself Regan
Harrison and Lord Noxon or the chosen
few who have been acknowledged by Lord
we go himself if you enjoy our work you
can support more of it by going over to
patreon.com slash anime uproar and
becoming a patron today for as little as
$1 if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos along side
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patient only discord
so check out patreon.com/lenguin
and until next time see you space cowboy
[Music]
you